19 ceases is an MLB pitcher and he's
part of MLB network's coverage of the of
the world of baseball including Yankees
at Red Sox tonight and tomorrow night at
7:00 Eastern Time he's out lighter how
you been out good how are you I'm doing
fine I I don't even know what to make of
last night what do you make of last
night you sound a little down a little
no I know it's early but it seems that
things are none of nothing's going right
for Arron Boone in the early going so
I'm just wondering what to take out and
meanwhile on the flip side Alex Cora is
9 and 1 so is Mickey Callaway two rookie
managers are 9 and 1 right now so what
do you take out of it you know I mean
you alluded to the statistic there with
a blowout the nine runs and the one
inning in the sixth I think listen do I
think that this lineup is gonna score
the Yankee lineup yes are they gonna hit
a lot of home runs yes I think there's
so much offense to go around did we
think that there was going to be a lot
of strikeouts yes I think when I look at
the roster and I'm just thinking out
loud as you as you turned you know threw
it to me I always think about when a
couple things when you have high
expectations for a team that that hasn't
been there per se and I'm saying dare I
say the New York Yankees I know they've
got all of the world championships but I
really believe this rich the teams that
I was on that had we went to the World
Series and won a World Championship and
I was lucky enough to be on a couple of
them you know there was always a couple
guys when you struggled or things just
didn't feel right and the rudder was
kind of flapping in the back of the boat
you kind of looked to the guy whether it
was a wind field or whether it was a
Paul Molitor or whether it was the late
Darren Daulton who was traded over at
the deadline we had a lot of great
players and I look at the Yankees now
and as good as they're going to be and I
believe in them I really do
you you look at the team and it's it's
it's either a young team or guys that
that haven't been there done that and I
think if you look at the Astros my point
is this rich there's always great young
talented players you go through a couple
rough patches usually two or three even
playoff teams you don't want any
gated losing streak and you kind of turn
to the guy who either is starting or
he's on the back end of his career and
he kind of takes the guys to dinner and
you hang and you talk about you know the
experiences and how you get through this
I'm looking at the roster now and yes of
course you have CC Sabathia who's down
with an injury you know there's some
really nice players but there really
isn't the guy Carlos Beltran a couple
years ago Matt Holliday last year I know
Gardner's been around a long time and
I've been part of the organization but a
lot is being thrown on still young and I
will say an experience now the junk all
the stands been around and I and and he
is an established MVP type player but
you know where do you go didi Gregorius
love them starting out has been super
but you know Tyler Austin at first
Miguel Andujar you know you got Robinson
who they bring up now in the outfield
and of course judge is great as he is
he's a young player Gary Sanchez I know
we keep talking about Stanton but
Sanchez you know has not hit you know
he's been he's been really bad I mean I
think is under 100 so when that happens
you need a little calmness you need a
little sense of you know who do we turn
to kind of thing and I they're gonna be
fine and I'm not painting a picture that
you know they're gonna be you know this
is going to continue but again you come
out of spring training there's this
anticipation that your team was a went
away from going to the World Series
nobody expected that last year and now
with the addition of Stanton you know
this team is destined to go the
postseason and World Series a lighter
here on the Rich Eisen show so which has
been the most pleasant surprise for you
so far this early part of the season
there's there's a couple of that might
be a candidate but what do you have for
me around for Major League Baseball as a
whole yeah just know I'll tell you what
I mean the Mets just glare out with that
with it with the spectacular listen we
knew that the Mets were going to be good
based on what they're starting pitching
are they going to be healthy we knew
that capability while I'm impressed with
the nine and one with the Red Sox I'm
not terribly surprised that they're off
to shoot but I mean listen the Mets
being nine and one fantastic who would
have figured you get rid of your your
iconic outfielder and your ace pitcher
the Pittsburgh Pirates respectively get
Cole and andrew mccutchen and you're now
first place in the central after ten
games eight and two that to me is is
another nice pleasant surprise I thought
Arizona would be solid you know so for
the positive plus side no question about
I think the Pirates and the Mets really
have stood out out lighter here on the
Rich Eisen show Mike Scioscia said Otani
reminded him of Dwight Gooden your
thoughts out like wow
I'll tell you what Mike Scioscia that's
a good comparison in the sense with you
know other than the split-finger that
Dwight Gooden didn't have
I mean Otani to me I still think and I
and I'm going to stay by it only because
it hasn't happened since Babe Ruth that
I think Otani eventually will be just a
pitcher and and it's not that I want
that because I think it's really cool to
see a player that has the ability that
Otani showing now that can hit and pitch
but he's just so good rich I mean here's
a guy that's consistently in the mid to
upper 90s he's got two breaking balls
he's got the big curve ball as you
alluded to with social comparison the
Dwight Gooden back in the day but no
tiny split finger I mean it's very
similar to a lot of the Japanese
pitchers and I think a Tanaka and
thinking about Yankees and watching
Tanaka up close so right now I mean this
guy he he's he's got it all 13 innings
in the H 18 strikeouts phenomenal and
exciting I think he's the type of guy
that they're you know a lot of people
are gonna be watching and bearing down
and you know watching him a lot closer
the fact that you got to pay a possible
two-way player and how many players over
the years since Babe Ruth tried it and
couldn't do it right I just it just
seems to be again I know this is first
blush and could be overreaction
but just why why not just III guess
that's the way so she's gonna play it
right is that he's gonna throw him out
there every fifth day give him about
three starts during a week last night we
saw him because I guess so she gave
everybody what they went what they
wanted which was a pinch-hit appearance
against Bartolo cologne which was just
something I will never forget
I'm so glad so she gave us that last
night but I guess that's the way he's
going to handle him right I mean that's
the way it's gonna go he's not he can't
see
in between starts Wow you saying you
know what so truthfully rich I haven't
really seen exactly how he's handled him
between his two starts now but my guest
tells me you don't play him the next day
the day after I start just because my
shoulder elbow training in the training
room with the with your trainer into the
weight room doing all of your really
hard work that's your hard work day I
imagine but is this where is this where
he is game day 2 3 4 or day 2 3 I
wouldn't play him every day before his
start I would want him to mentally
prepare into game fire or day 5 is that
how he's doing it yeah it looks like it
I mean he did not start him last night
gave him a little bit of a look-see
you know he pitched on on Sunday so he
gave him a couple of days off I'm
imagining he should be in the lineup
tonight right I know I hate throwing out
a question on there but when is this
next start I didn't uh I didn't say
Sunday against Kansas City so he's good
yes he's going Sunday to Sunday and
imagine just get some hits in between
and I mentioned this to Jason stark
yesterday I'm like why not see what we
got here and and the goal for me as a
fan is that he's the starting American
League Pitcher in DC in July for the
all-star game
and bats third in the lineup that would
be incredible could you imagine that now
the starting pitcher would that wouldn't
surprise me but if he were to yep sorry
pitchers yeah cool would that be
listen I'm all in man and it sounds like
because I've said on MLB Network you
know it was kind of you know he's a
pitcher he's a pitcher because I love
his stuff and how many times do we have
to see you know it's him being wrong or
or Adam Wainwright or or
a couple years ago Charlie Morton you
know running down the basis and gets
hurt right god you'd hate to see that
because I still think his future is more
as a picture even though as he's got
three home runs he's about 360 something
that would be pretty cool if he was able
to pull that off yeah I know I know but
Waymon real quick so you mention it I'm
trying to sure there he's going he's
pitching every seven days well I guess
just because of the way that this all
worked out this week Chris is that the
way with off days and things of that
yeah I think they're just going Sunday
to Sunday with them that's that's what
it's been for the first time and
rotation huh that's what it looks like
right now and why not I mean it's
working I mean Paul said six sixteen of
his career trout wait another bomb last
night
they destroyed Texas they look good and
they're often I mean up tonight I love
that pickup of court Charles can be
trialed whatever you get from Albert's
gonna get over 3,000 hits that's
exciting you got the best defensive
shortstop in the game and Simmons III
like what they're doing I really do is
that Kosar but what a year he had with
the Reds holding down second base this
is a nice team yeah he's the agent today
that's that's official Scioscia is
putting them in the D H spot today L so
it'll be fun
must-see I don't know you're at
California right now I'm telling you
Masters on one screen on Sunday o Thani
with his perfect game on another I think
you know if he continues just let's just
have fun here and do the crystal ball
twice to put it even come close to from
Nando mania in the early people are
talking about it out here ready again I
don't want to get too good over my skis
here but if o'donneii
can continue on right and if he's the
starting pitcher for the American League
and you I found the manager I'm
absolutely because they're gonna bat
first put him in the put him in the
first put him in the three hole right
put him in the three hole to start
things off and then have him throw the
first inning and then take him out as a
pitcher that would be as exciting as bo
Jackson playing in the all-star game
your that it's pretty tough but guess
what hits it's the second start of 15
starts before they pick an all-star
it breaks out don't make me pump the
brakes
is there a nickname we've come up with a
handful of them dudes is Otani have one
yet in the MLB network say hey show hey
I'll bet the the show hey kid I've seen
that write the show hey kid kinda like
that the big show show hey the money for
me my home run call if I was back on
SportsCenter if he goes the other way
and hits one out it would be a potent
Enochs I like that about Tony nut yeah
take it take it
go photon Enochs I'll use it or I'll
hand it over to dad please act they go
left he's all like hanging out together
I got it al thanks for the call take
care we'll check you that's he's one of
the best the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience